he's got one shoe right now trying to  play at the defensive end got blown back  yes Jim  yeah and flex on him jaylen Brown  spectacular play by Brown over the grief  now watch as he goes you want to see it  right here  everything is fine until he faced him  right I'm telling people hitting his  second three-pointer leaders at 14 nice  cut by crown and slams it in over Yanis  this is just good basketball once I make  the move to two on the ball here right  now make the cut from the opposite side  of the floor why because your defensive  man turned his head and you backdoor him  the ball will be there  back out to Jaylin Brown  now out of time that was impressive  Ilana he came putting on his tongue  watch him  Wow come on people are still sick so I'm  not going to let you do it two times on  to tip exactly the place  [Applause]